EMILY RIEDERER: Hi, my
name is Emily Riederer.
And today, I'm here to
talk about how to design
packages for your organization.
Think about the last time that
you joined a new organization.
There was so much you
needed to learn before you
can start contributing.
You remember the frustration
when you couldn't figure out
how to access data,
the lost hours
trying to answer the wrong
question before you built up
to your intuition,
and the awkwardness
of figuring out team norms
through trial and error.
When we join a new
organization, we
must learn these things
only once before we
can hit the ground running.
However, the off-the-shelves
tools that we use
can't preserve this context.
Every day is like their
first day at work.
Unlike open-source
packages, internal packages
can embrace
institutional knowledge
more like a colleague
in two important ways.
First and foremost,
they can aim to solve
far more domain-specific
and concrete problems
than open-source packages.
Second, although narrow
versions of the scope
of the defined problem, their
insight into our organization
allows them to be more
holistic in the solutions
they propose by
internalizing more steps
of the necessary workflow
to answer that question,
covering areas like pulling
data and communicating
with colleagues.
Because of these two
factors, internal packages
can add a lot of value by
interfacing internal utilities,
streamlining the
analysis process,
and empowering data scientists
to create high-quality results.
But more than the
tasks they can do,
today, I want to talk
about how to design
such internal packages to be
as rich in context as possible.
To do this, I like to
think about the popular
Jobs-To-Be-Done framework
for product development.
This asserts that
we hire a product
to do a job that helps us make
progress towards the goal.
And to me, it's that
notion of progress
and truly knowing the ins and
outs of what sort of progress
our users need to make that
sets internal packages apart.
Additionally, these jobs
can add functional, social,
and emotional aspects.
For the rest of this
discussion, I'll
tweak this framework
just slightly.
Let's build a team
of packages to do
the jobs that help our org
answer impactful questions
with efficient workflows.
So, what sort of teammate
should our packages be?
Let's meet a few.
First, I'd like to
introduce you to the IT guy.
Think of a helpful or friendly
IT or dev-ops colleague
that you may know.
They're fantastic at handling
the quirks of infrastructure
and abstracting away
all the sorts of things
that data scientists don't
want to spend their time
thinking about, like proxies,
connections, servers, et
cetera.
In that extraction
process, they also
take on additional
responsibilities
to promote good practices, like
data security and credential
management.
Ideally, they can save us a
lot of time and frustration
in navigating
organization-specific
roadblocks that no amount of
searching on Stack Overflow
can help.
So, how can we encode these
characteristics in a package?
Providing utility
functions can help achieve
that same type of abstraction.
And in these functions, we
can take an opinionated stance
and craft helpful
error messages.
Let's take a look at an example.
Suppose we want to write a
function to connect ourselves
to a database.
First, we might start out with
a rather boilerplate piece
of code using the DBI package.
We take in the user name and
password, hard code the driver
name, server location, port, and
return the connection object.
Now, let's suppose
our organization has
strict rules against
putting secure credentials
in plain text, as
well they should.
In an open-source
package, I wouldn't
presume to force users hands to
use one specific system set up.
However, in this case, we
can make strong assumptions
based on our knowledge of an
organization's rules and norms.
And this sort of function
can be great leverage
to incentivize users
to do the right thing,
like storing their credentials
in environment variables.
Because it's the only way they
can get the function to work.
Of course, that's only helpful
if we provide descriptive error
messages when the user does not
have their credentials set up
this way.
Otherwise, they'll get an
error that DB_PSS is missing,
find nothing useful online
to help them troubleshoot
since this is an internal
choice that we made.
So we can enhance this function
with an extremely custom
and prescriptive error
message explaining
what went wrong and
either how to fix it
or where we can get
more information.
Of course, even better
than explaining errors
is preventing them
from occurring at all.
We might also know at
specific organization
that non-alphanumeric characters
are required in passwords
and the DB_CONNECT doesn't
natively encode these correctly
when passing them
to the database.
Instead of troubling the
user and telling them
how to put their
password, we can instead
handle this silently
inside of the function.
However, strong opinions
in complete independence
don't always make
a great colleague.
Other times, we might
want someone more
like a junior analyst.
They know a good bit
about the organization.
And we can trust them to execute
calculations correctly and make
reasonable assumptions.
At the same time,
we want them to be
responsive to our feedback
and willing to try things out
in more ways than one.
So, how can we capture these
jobs in an internal package?
We can build interactive
yet responsive functions
with default arguments, reserved
keywords, and the ellipsis.
To illustrate, imagine a
basic visualization function
that reacts ggplot to code
but allows users to input
their preferred x, y,
and grouping variables
to draw cohort curves.
This function's fine.
But we can probably draw
on institutional knowledge
to push our junior analyst to be
a little bit more interactive.
If we relied on the
same opinionated design
as the IT guy, we might consider
putting some of the variables
inside of the function.
Here though, that
isn't a great approach,
it isn't the junior
analyst's job to give edicts.
We might know what the desired
x-axis will be 80% of the time,
but hard coding here is
too strong of an assumption
and decreases the usefulness of the
function for that other 20%.
Instead, we can put
our best guess 80%
right names as the default
arguments in the function
header, ordered by decreasing
likelihood of the need
to override.
This means when users do
not provide their own value,
a default is used.
That's the junior
analyst's best guess,
but users retain
complete control
to change it as they see fit.
This approach becomes even more
powerful if we can abstract out
a small set of incredibly
common, frequently occurring,
assumed variable
names or other values.
We can define and
document this set
of keywords, or
special variable names,
that span all of our
internal packages.
If these are well known
and well documented,
users will get into the habit
of shaping their data so it
plays nice with the
package ecosystem
and saves a lot
of manual typing.
This type of incentive
to standardize filenames
can have other
convenient consequences
in making data
extracts more shareable
and code more readable.
Finally, one other
nice trick in making
our functions
responsive to feedback
is the ellipsis, or
passing the dots.
This allows users to provide
any number of arbitrary
additional arguments beyond what
was specified by the developer
and plugs them in
at a designated
place in the function body.
This way users can
extend functions
based on needs that
the developer could not
have anticipated, like
customizing the color, size,
and line type.
So far, we've mostly focused
on that first dimension,
making our package
teammates targeted solving
specific internal problems.
But there's just as much value
in that second dimension,
using internal packages as a way
to ship not just calculations,
but workflows and to share
an understanding of how
the broader
organization operates.
To illustrate this, consider
our intrepid tech lead.
We value this type of
teammate because they
can draw from a breadth
of past experience
and institutional knowledge
to help you weigh trade offs,
learn from corrupted
wisdom, and inspire
you to do your best work.
So, that's a pretty tall
order to put in a package,
but conscientious use of
vignettes and templates
can help us towards this goal.
Vignettes often help
introduce basic functionality
of a package with a toy example,
as found in the dplyr vignette,
or less commonly they may
discuss the statistical method
that's implemented, as done
in the survival package.
Vignettes of an
internal R package
can do more diverse
numerous jobs.
These vignettes can accumulate
the hard-won experience
and domain knowledge like
an experienced tech lead's
photographic memory, and they
hand deliver these insights
to anyone currently working
on a related analysis.
Just as a few examples,
you can consider
having completely code free
vignettes that conceptually
introduce you to common problem
that your package solves,
explain the workflow
and key questions you
should be asking
yourself along the way,
and even potentially get
into procedural weeds--
like what you need to do to
add features or deploy a model.
Then, after aligning
with your users
on a conceptual
framework, you may
introduce the package's
functionality and explain
how those two overlap.
When your package
contains functions
for many different
ways to do a task,
you can also compare
pros and cons
and explain different situations
where different ones have
proven more or less effective.
Finally, vignettes can also
include lessons learned,
reflections from past users,
and references to past examples
to help analysts learn
about similar projects.
In fact, all of that context
may be so helpful even to people
that are not direct
users of your package,
they may want to seek
it's much mentorship.
In this case, you can use
the pkgdown package
to automatically create a
package website to share
these vignettes with anyone
who needs to learn more
about a specific problem space.
With a single function
call, your package
can share it's
wisdom more broadly.
And, unlike their
human counterparts,
the package tech lead can always
find time for another meeting.
Similar to vignettes,
embedded templates
take on a more important
and distinctive role
for internal packages.
In open source packages,
R Markdown templates
provide a prepopulated file,
instead of the default.
This is most commonly used to
demonstrate proper formatting
syntax.
For example, the
flexdashboard package
uses a template so users how
to set up the yaml metadata
and section headers.
Instead, internal packages can
use templates to coach users
through workflows
because they understand
the problems users are
facing and the progress
they hope to achieve.
Internal packages can mentor
users and structure their work
in two different ways.
Process walkthroughs can
serve as interactive notebooks
that coach users
through common analyses.
As an example, if
a type of analysis
requires manual data
cleaning and curation,
a template notebook
can guide users
to ask the right
questions of their data
and generate common views
they need to analyze.
We can also include full end-
to-end analysis outlines which
include placeholder
text, commentary,
and code, if the
type of analysis
that a package supports
usually results
in a specific type of report.
Similarly, our package can
include a project template, not
just an R Markdown template.
These templates can predefine
a standard file structure
and a boilerplate set of
files for a new project
to give users a helping hand and
drive the kind of consistency
across projects that
any tech lead dreams
of when doing a code review.
Speaking of
collaboration brings us
to the last teammate whose
traits we want our package
to evoke, the project manager.
One of the biggest
differences between task-
doing versus problem-
solving packages
is understanding
the whole workflow
and helping
coordinate the project
across different components.
When writing open
source packages,
we rightly assume that our
intended audience is R users,
but on a true cross-functional
internal team,
not everyone will be,
so we can intentionally
modularize the
workflow and think
about how to augment
RStudio's IDE to make sure
our tools work well with
all of our colleagues.
One way to do this
is with modularizing
the parts of the
workflow that really
do or do not require R code.
For example, in the
templates we just discussed,
we could actually make
separate template components
for the parts that
require R code
and for the parts that are just
English text and commentary.
The commentary files can be
plain vanilla Markdown files
that any collaborator
could edit without even
having to have R installed.
And the main R Markdown
can pull in this plain text
output using child documents.
This approach is
now made even easier
with advances in
the RStudio IDE.
The visual Markdown editor
provides a great graphical user
interface to support
word-processing
in Markdown for those plain
text narrative documents
that we just discussed.
We can also use RStudio add-ins
to extend the RStudio interface
and ship interactive widgets
in our internal packages.
To illustrate, I've shown the
point and click plot coding
assistant from the open
source esquisse package.
Add-ins require more
investment upfront
but they're much
easier to maintain
than a full application.
And they can help convert
teammates to R users.
Besides, a good
project manager is
willing to go that extra
mile to support their team.
Now, speaking of
collaboration, we've
talked about what can
make an individual package
a good teammate, another
major opportunity when
building a suite
of internal tools
is that we can think about how
multiple packages on our team
can best work together.
We want teammates that
are clear communicators,
have defined responsibilities,
and keep their promises.
We can help packages be
these sorts of good teammates
with naming conventions,
clearly defined
scopes, and careful attention
to dependencies and testing.
Clear function
naming conventions
and consistent method signatures
help packages effectively
communicate with both package
and human collaborators.
Internally, we can give our
suite of internal packages
a richer language by defining
a consistent set of prefixes
through name stubs
that indicate how
each function is to be used.
One approach I like is
that each function prefix
can denote the type of object
that that function will return.
For example, using viz
prefixes for functions
that return ggplot2 objects.
This way, past
experience working
with one internal
package seamlessly
translates to the next.
Another aspect of good
team communication
is having clearly defined
roles and responsibilities.
Again, since we own our whole
internal stack of packages,
we have more freedom
in how we can
choose to divide
up functionality
and responsibilities
across packages.
Take for example,
the data science
workflow as described in
the R for Data Science book.
Open source packages inevitably
have overlapping functionality,
which forces users to compare
alternatives and decide
which is best.
Internally, we can use some
amount of central planning
to ensure each package teammate
has a clearly defined role,
whether that be to provide
a horizontal utility
or to enable progress on
a specific work stream.
And just like one team ought
to work well with another,
that central planning can
include curation and promotion
of open source tools along
with our internal ones.
After all, no one team
can do it all alone.
When assigning these roles
to our team of packages,
we should consider how to manage
the dependencies between them
when different
functionality needs
to be shared across packages.
Packages often have
direct dependencies
where a function in one package
calls a function in another.
This is not necessarily
bad, but especially
with internal packages,
which might sometimes
have a shorter shelf life
and fewer developers,
this can sometimes
create a domino effect.
If one package is deprecated,
or decides to retire or take
a vacation, we don't want the
rest of our ecosystem affected.
Alternatively, we
can use the fact
that both packages A and
B are under our control
to see if we can eliminate
the explicit dependency
by promoting a clean handoff.
We can see if a function
in A can produce an output
that B can consume instead of
calling A's function directly.
Additionally, because
we own the full stack,
we may also consider if there
are shared needs in A and B
that should be extracted
into a common building block
package C. For instance, a
set of common visualization
function primitives,
this way we at least have
a clear hierarchy of
dependencies instead
of a spiderweb and can identify
a small number of truly
essential ones.
Regardless of the type of
dependencies we end up with,
we can use tests to make
sure our packages are
reliable teammates who
do what they promised.
Typically, if I write package
B that depends on package A,
I can only control
package B's tests.
So, I could write tests
to see if A continues
to perform as B is expecting.
This is a good safeguard but
it means that we will only
detect problems after they've
already been introduced in A.
There's nothing in
place to actually stop
package A from getting
distracted in the first place.
Instead, we prefer
that both A and B
be conscientious of the
promises they've made
and stay committed to working
towards their shared goal.
We can formalize that shared
vision with integration tests,
that is, we can
add tests to both
the upstream and the
downstream packages
to ensure they continue to check
in with each other and inquire
of any of the changes they're
planning could be disruptive.
Now, just imagine having
such rigorous and ongoing
communication and prioritization
with your own teammates.
In summary, we all know the joy
of working with a great team,
and, given that you're
here right now,
I suspect you know the pleasure
of cracking open a new R
package.
By taking advantage of
the unique opportunities
of designing
internal packages we
can achieve the
best of both worlds.
We can share the fun of
working with good tools
with the teammates we care about
and we can elevate those tools
to full fledged teammates by
giving them the skills they
need to succeed.
Thank you.